you were one great queen of mean Audrey
you were totally believable as a villain
after all jealousy is a powerful
motivator the sleeping spell you cast
over auradon was pretty fitting
considering your mom is sleeping beauty
but we had to wonder why you cast that
aging first on now surely putting her to
sleep would have been more effective at
keeping her from beating you why is that
the spell you decided to use in
descendants three Audrey cast a spell
that mean mal turn into a feeble old
woman there are a lot of reasons why
Audrey didn't just put mal to sleep keep
watching to find out why Audrey's
history audrey is the daughter of Aurora
Phillip she grew up as a princess so she
had a lot of expectations about her life
her grandmother Queen Leah definitely
spoiled her Leah made it clear that she
expected Audrey to marry a king and
become a queen and since Audrey was the
same age as Ben it was pretty easy to
figure out who she should marry she and
Ben weren't close from a very young age
in descendants 3 we see all sorts of
pictures from their childhood when they
got older they started dating then might
not have been in love with Audrey but
Audrey was definitely in love with Ben
Audrey also grew up hearing all the
horrible things about Maleficent
Maleficent is one of the evilest Disney
villains and she was basically the top
villain on the Isle of the Lost
Maleficent is the one who cursed
Audrey's mom as a baby
and turned into a dragon to fight her
dad it's no wonder that Audrey was
pretty skeptical of the V case when they
arrived in auradon when Mao and the
other V case arrived in auradon Audrey
was convinced that they were wicked and
she wasn't wrong
you will find the fairy godmother and
you will bring me back her magic wand
easy peasy
think believe now did the right thing at
the end but Audrey and mal did not get
along
Audrey pretended to be nice because
she's a princess in auradon but she was
suspicious of mal
she was also upset because she could
tell that Ben was into mal and then Ben
fell under Mao's love spell which broke
Audrey's heart it was even worse when
she realized that Ben actually did love
mal her entire life plan was ruined plus
she was heartbroken the aging fell
Audrey was super angry at the end of
descendants when been declared his love
for mouth so she went away for a while
Audrey returns in descendents 3 she's
convinced that mal has ruined her life
so when Ben proposes she realizes her
chance at becoming Queen is gone her
godmother is really mean to her about
not getting what she wanted our family
started gone she's so sad that her
chance with Ben is gone so she does
something really extreme she breaks into
the museum to steal the Queen's crown
but then she sees Maleficent scepter and
steals that too she cast a sleeping
spell over all of auradon she runs into
mal and casts
[Laughter]
turning mal into an old woman doesn't
make a lot of sense if now we're asleep
like everyone else she wouldn't be a
threat to Audrey but Audrey has been
super jealous of mal since the V Ches
arrived in auradon you can see her
jealousy in the curse
Audrey values appearances a lot she's
always dressed perfectly with great hair
she wanted Mao to look ugly she sees mal
as wicked and she wanted her to look the
part
she also knew that mal took a lot of
pride in her own appearance so aging her
was humiliating but it was also more
than just jealousy Audrey had been
feeling completely out of control of her
life she planned every moment only to
have been fall in love with Mal Audrey
wanted Mao to feel just as powerless
turning mal into an old woman who could
barely move was the perfect way to do
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
now had to watch all of her friends fall
under the sleeping spell and eventually
turned to stone but as an old lady she
could barely move we can see that audrey
was still struggling with the good
inside of her she was acting out of
anger and jealousy but she could have
done something a lot worse to mal the
curse was also extra meaningful because
Audrey used Maleficent scepter knowing
that it was her mom's magic that Audrey
channeled had to hurt mal pretty
terribly but Audrey was tempted by the
power to regain control of her life all
she wanted was to be queen happily ever
after Audrey didn't expect mouths curse
to break so easily
I'm Malin Audrey had an epic showdown
mal saved auradon but audrey fell into a
cursed sleep even though Audrey had
hated mal and threatened auradon now
still did whatever she could to save her
she convinced Ben to bring Hades who
used his Ember to save Audrey thankfully
Audrey realized she had made a terrible
mistake she was grateful for mal saving
her and realized that she wasn't truly
wicked even Audrey's grandmother came
around
Audrey admitted she was wrong and she
accepted that she wouldn't become queen
we know it won't be easy but mal and
Audrey will be able to overcome their
history and be friends Plus Audrey might
have found her happily ever after she
and Harry husk looked pretty cozy at the
end of the movie what fell would you
cast with Maleficent scepter let us know
in the comments thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to this day's we'll
see you next
[Music]